je sais que l'amour existe
bonjour inspecteurs ronson
vous pouvez me dire où vous étiez
je prends les gens leur voix à l'heure
leurs formes leurs regards leurs
souvenirs leurs espoirs et leurs rêves
tous qui vais tout ce qui fait de
quelqu'un ce qu'il est je le prends et
je le garde pour de bon viens ici rachel
vous pensez être une bonne personne
savoir si être bon c'est vraiment
important de mauvaises choses arrivent
souvent à de bonnes personnes
[Musique]
si je ne fais pas ça je vais mourir
je ne suis pas prêt à me rien ce qui
veut dire que vous y
dans les moments de calme mes pensées
vont toujours vers elle et tu penses
qu'on a ça une connexion je pense que
nous sommes des âmes soeurs
il ya quelque chose de das est familier
chez toi
ah ah
il ne t'arrivera jamais rien de mal avec
moi c'est promis